children are getting disease that we've
never seen before there are two diseases
that we never before saw in children
type 2 diabetes and fatty liver disease
prior to 1980 these two diseases were
the diseases of alcoholics today we have
30% of children who manifest some form
of non-alcoholic fatty liver disease and
type 2 diabetes is now approaching the
same incidence as type 1 diabetes in
children sugar and alcohol are
metabolized virtually identically in the
liver and it makes sense that that would
be the case because after all where do
you get alcohol from fermentation of
sugar it's called wine so the big
difference between these two molecules
is that for alcohol the yeast does the
first step of metabolism for sugar we do
our own first step of metabolism but
after that the liver doesn't care where
it came from and when you overload the
liver with either one you get the same
diseases so we are seeing the diseases
of alcohol ravage the entire population
of the United States without alcohol the
food industry grosses 1.4 trillion
dollars a year of which 45% is gross
profit that's 657 billion dollars in
gross profit the closest industry to
that is Big Pharma at 18%
we on the other hand spend three point
two trillion dollars a year in health
care of which 75% is chronic disease of
which 75% of that is potentially
preventable if we could go back to 1970
rates so if you do the math on that that
is 1.8 trillion dollars a year going
down a rat hole we spend triple what the
food industry makes cleaning up their
mess this is unsustainable and it's the
reason that both Medicare and Social
Security are going broke
[Music]